hello there watching the press preview a
first look then at what is on the front
pages time to see what's making the
headlines with matthew syed columnist
for the times and sunday times and the
broadcaster and political commentator
salma shah welcome to both of you
seismic times indeed with that breaking
news this evening but let's see how the
newspapers have managed to cover the
story so far the guardian leading with
the story that a number of afghan
children are feared dead after a u.s
drone strike near kabul the telegraph
says the raf is ready to launch fresh
strikes against isis k militants in
afghanistan
while the time says the pentagon appears
to be blaming the uk for last week's
suicide bomb at kabul airport allegedly
by keeping open the gate where it
happened
longest day that is the lead for the
metro which focuses on those afghans who
are still hoping to flee kabul as the
last western forces pull out
but as the sun puts it we're in charge
now with pictures of taliban members
wearing afghan police
uniforms
well the financial times says that a
surge in covert cases in three u.s
states has sparked fears that travel
restrictions may have to be reimposed by
the eu
while the daily mail leads with news
that ministers are looking at attacks on
disposable nappies to try to get parents
to switch to greener alternatives
delhi express has another its many
recent stories about threats to scrap
the pensions triple lock with a warning
to the chancellor not to double cross
pensioners
and the daily mirror looks forward to
british summertime 2022 the headline we
do love to be beside our seaside
so let's bring in matthew said from the
times broadcaster and political
commentator sulma shah welcome to both
of you um i suppose the prize goes to
the metro for updating their front page
we saw an old one there
their new front page already says the
last flight um matthew
celebratory gunfire from the taliban in
kabul and it all came to an end so
quickly
matthew apologies i think you need to
unmute yourself
apology it's been so long since i've
done this i i it's a phrase that i've
heard often over the course of the
pandemic but apologies i had i had muted
um i think this has been a obviously a
huge strategic reversal uh for the west
the the folly of trying to nation build
to impose our values and sensibilities
on a society that is
so incredibly different from a cultural
perspective
a tribal perspective the ethnic
affiliations that predated the formation
of the nation of afghanistan
i think it's a mistake to focus too much
on the i mean it's a terrible error that
the allies have made in the chaos of the
withdrawal the letting down of people
who supported us uh whilst we were there
for this two decade period but that
shouldn't obscure the key strategic
misjudgments of the blair and bush era
and unless we're capable of extracting
the lessons from this very sorry history
i don't think we'll be in a position to
adequately shape the future in the
interests of the west
and to combat a increasingly resurgent
and confident china so sorry just to to
for you to explain what you mean more
specifically do you mean leaving
afghanistan enjoying joining a field of
conflict in iraq at the time and not
effectively finishing the job what what
which of the strategic areas you're
talking about
so
i think at the bond talks the original
strategic error is that the bond talks
of 2001 we tried to create a coherent
nation state along western lines uh
talib that afghanistan is a nation
divide i mean 14 ethnicities are
mentioned in the national anthem and
these ethnic allegiances are historic
they're ancient
they've been warring for many hundreds
if not thousands of years
and it was i think a mistake in that
original conception and then of course
we backed the northern alliance uh in
its attempt to overturn the taliban in
the period after
without recognizing that the taliban
isn't just a group of religious
fundamentalists it's also dominated by
ethnic pashtuns and the majority passion
and population became paranoid that the
tajiks and uzbek dominated northern
alliance would carry out terrible
reprisals which they did but this tribal
blind spot in western foreign policy
isn't just true of afghanistan it's true
of vietnam it's true of iraq it's a
litany of errors and we haven't yet
learned from our mistakes and i hope
very much
uh that despite i think we're right to
focus on the chaos of the withdrawal we
need to learn that central lesson if
we're going to get our foreign policy uh
better in the future yeah that's
interesting you're drawing on
geopolitics history the complexity of
the situations on the ground it's hard
to make a newspaper headline out of that
though isn't it the guardian for example
selma uh afghan children feared dead in
u.s drone strike a family of 10
multiple children more children
that died in this some of them very
young and it's easy to focus on these
incidents is it not which is now yet
again the front of terror in afghanistan
against isis k
yeah i think this is important because
uh the issue is about what's happening
in the immediate and
matthew's right to focus on you know
learning lessons from this
afghan escapade but that is going to
happen in longer term right now we are
still not out of the situation so even
though the last flight has gone out of
afghanistan with safe passage and
agreement actually the fact that isis k
is going back in and has found a new
breeding ground where they've moved out
of syria and where they've been um holed
up in the in the recent in recent years
just goes to show that actually this is
not sort of a cliff edge where we're cut
and dry on this and actually sadly you
know in a u.s drone strike there's been
poor information that seems like it's
led to the death of these children and
that sort of
tragedy is going to become quite
symbolic of what is going to happen in
afghanistan i think for a long time yet
to come
so
the guardian focusing on those young
children
the question now is of those also left
behind
many have been in contact with
journalists or indeed military personnel
uk or otherwise that they've worked with
and they're desperate to get out they
may well have the right papers to get to
the uk for example matthew but how do
they do that do they walk to pakistan
where they're not allowed in i mean
these are desperate scenes which is a
reminder of what it is like which you we
don't necessarily understand in this
country of what it is like to live in
fear
yeah yeah that's right and i think the
people who are in fear of those who who
worked with with the west
um and they doubtless are rational in
fearing reprisals uh potentially from
the taliban you will have noticed a
softening of the rhetoric from western
leaders about the taliban and
potentially wanting to work with them uh
and to provide aid the only leverage
that i can see the the main leverage
that the west has i think is uh
financial rather than military uh it's
an incredible thing to note that the gdp
in afghanistan is is about 20 billion
dollars uh compared with sort of three
trillion for the uk and over
20 trillion for the us and about 8
billion of that in afghanistan is aid so
we do have a bargaining chip and we may
well be able to cooperate with them in
trying to secure the release of some of
these people but that remains to be seen
we really don't know what kind of co i
mean the taliban we think of it as a
unified force it is a coalition itself a
very fragile coalition and i think it's
still very early to determine what kind
of a uh polity will emerge from this i
mean it's not impossible that
afghanistan will defend uh descend as it
did after the soviet occupation into
another very bitter and very bloody
civil war yes we watch and wait don't we
we'll see and see what happens but
certainly the u.s operation with the
drone strikes that we've seen uh selma
picks us to the or leads us to the daily
telegraph which suggests that the raf
itself is ready to
launch or join in with those attacks the
raf the paper says ready to launch fresh
islamic state strikes in afghanistan and
this is the great fear now not just
there but in terms of the export of
terrorism too
exactly i mean this is the reason that
uh you know western powers went into
afghanistan in the first place because
it was targeting al
um whereas in some cases you can think
of the taliban as benign because it acts
domestically
but it allows uh the breeding ground for
international terrorism so you know isis
k is today's al-qaeda
i think the issue is that if the raf is
prepared to to do this and support the
u.s with air strikes you know is there
going to be a question further down the
line as to whether we need to do this
independently without u.s support there
are also gaps in questions around what
the us is willing to do and it's not
really showing its hand as well as
trying to understand um you know where
the taliban might move
from from where it was 20 years ago and
whether they can be a power that we can
negotiate with and negotiate with with
our leverage as matthew rightly points
out with aid or whether we are going to
have to use a firmer hand and have these
threats of airstrikes constantly hanging
over them
the uk defense secretary matthew talked
about his belief of 1 100 people that
they would have liked to get out the
guardian uh says that mps are scrambling
to rescue more than 7 000 constituents
and family members trapped in
afghanistan according to figures
provided to the guardian scores of
labour mps have been inundated with
pleas for help from thousands of
constituents whose relatives have been
left stranded since the uk's final
emergency airlift left kabul i mean
you know i mean we're going back to
those left behind it's not it's not the
only part of this story but really these
are people who who fear for their lives
and to have family connections in the uk
and have the right paperwork um it just
almost shows the inability now of the
west to do anything about it we're in
the hands of the taliban if i can put it
that way
yeah this is true and it's also worth
bearing in mind that those who escape
because of the clan
the structure of afghan society they
will have extended kin who are left back
in afghanistan who may well themselves
be on the receiving end of reprisals
because often in these kinds of
societies there is corporate guilt if a
person does something wrong you can take
revenge on their cousin or some other
clan proxy so it's a horribly difficult
situation one thing to bear in mind
however is it's very difficult to get an
accurate analysis of public opinion in
afghanistan but one survey by pew in
2013 is that 99 of the afghan population
these are not the people who we're
seeing on our screens at the moment
favor sharia law 85 percent favor
stoning for adultery
um and 80
another pretty brutal retribution for a
certain type of religious crime so it is
quite when we talk about we need to do
something like this for the afghan
people who hate the taliban it's very
difficult to tell exactly what level of
support there is within afghanistan for
the taliban but i would say that part of
that support is a deep fear of the chaos
that could ensue if there is no
unifying power however awful that i mean
that's really interesting isn't it um
we've always wondered how many afghans
would support the taliban over what was
there um but we heard today also from
uh foreign secretaries osama and the u.n
security council
this this ambition that the gains of the
last 20 years mainly in women's rights
and rights for minorities i suppose
should not be lost and how fainter hope
is there for those looking on that those
gains will be allowed to continue
this is so tricky because the reaction
of of those women who've held prominent
positions in their scramble in some
high-profile cases to leave afghanistan
suggest that the taliban are not
in any mind um to want to try and uh
hold on to any of those any of that
progress
so
i think it is an incredibly faint hope
and as you've just heard you know sharia
law is
built and stacked against women and this
is what the taliban fundamentally
believe this is an ideological core so i
think it's sort of
i have to say slightly ridiculous of us
to think that the taliban is going to
change and allow any of this progress
and we have to sort of steal ourselves
to the fact that this is going to be
a real tragedy and again
even though we were there and there for
20 years and this progress was made um
you know under western powers
essentially supporting an afghan
government
this is not the primary reason that we
were there and if we talk about sort of
the various things that that are in the
ether at the moment you know
this is not part of our strategic
military interest and we'll wait to see
whether there's enough sort of domestic
good will towards this progress to be
able to
to keep it going through the afghan
people because certainly there is no
indication that the taliban is going to
want to keep this going well salma
matthew stay there lots more still to
come more from the newspapers uh still
waiting to hear also from the u.s
secretary of state
after these scenes in kabul
[Applause]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview just reminded that we are
waiting to hear from the u.s secretary
of state live from the state department
anthony blinken expected shortly we'll
take you there live when that happens in
the meantime let's continue our press
preview joining me now matthew side
columnist for the times and sunday times
and the broadcaster and political
commentator salma shah welcome to both
of you um divesting attention away from
afghanistan just briefly uh salma to the
ft
and this is uh the rising number of
cases of covid in the u.s uh means that
it's gone on the eu
no-fly zone if i can put it that way
yes this is quite a worrying development
because it looked like the us was
getting into a good place with its
vaccination program and according to the
ft it still is but there is huge
vaccination hesitancy which is uh i
think slowing down some of the progress
that the united states has made
the fact that the eu has put this um on
a no travel and no-flight restriction uh
is also quite worrying for the uk
because if we leave ourselves open to
the us could this mean
huge rises in covert case numbers
especially as we're going through a
process of uh having our own boosters
this winter so a hell of a lot of
northern nervousness i think as a result
of this news
uh just seeing also that the u.s
president while we just get more
breaking news on afghanistan says he
will address the american people on
afghanistan on tuesday that's according
to the white house and we will hear
words from the u.s president tomorrow
on the issue of afghanistan not
expecting him tonight
but he has written a statement saying
that he wanted to thank our commanders
and the men and women serving under them
for their execution of the dangerous
retrograde from afghanistan is scheduled
in the early morning of august the 31st
kabul time with no further loss of
american lives the past 17 days he says
have seen our troops execute the largest
airlift in u.s history evacuating more
than 120 000 u.s citizens citizens of
our allies the afghan allies of the
united states they have done it with
unmatched courage professionalism and
resolve now our 20-year military
presence in afghanistan he said has
ended tomorrow afternoon so that's
tuesday i will address the american
people on my decision not to extend our
presence in afghanistan beyond the 31st
of august for now i will report that it
was the unanimous recommendation of the
joint chiefs and of all of our
commanders on the ground to end our
airlift mission as planned
their view was that ending our military
mission was the best way to protect the
lives of our troops and secure the
prospect of civilian departures for
those who want to leave afghanistan in
the weeks and months ahead it goes on to
stay this is the statement from the u.s
president i've asked the secretary of
state to lead the continued coordination
with our international partners to
ensure safe passage for any americans
afghan partners and foreign nationals
who want to leave afghanistan this will
include work to build on the u.n
security council resolution passed this
afternoon that sent the clear message of
what the international community expects
of the taliban to deliver on moving
forward notably freedom of travel the
taliban the president said have made
commitments on safe passage and the
world will hold them to their
commitments the words there of the us
president we will return to our press
preview guests at half past eleven the
very latest on the situation in kabul
where there has been celebratory gunfire
from the taliban tonight coming up in a
few minutes time
[Applause]